[Applauso]
mi chiamo mor vengono al cambio 18 anni
sono arrivato in italia nel 2017 dopo un
lungo assedio tra verso la libia io non
lo so come sarà il futuro del mondo ma
vorrei raccontarvi la mia esperienza
perché credo che tutti possono essere
utili in questo mondo e chi cambia così
velocemente
non è solo chi ha i master in america e
vuole curare le malattie ma anche a chi
come me ha solo la terza media
mi piace l'idea di parlare di futuro
perché ho capito che come mi sento po di
non dipende solo dopo me il mio passato
lontano o cosa è successo stamattina ma
anche da come immagino il mio futuro
e questo è vero per me per tutti gli
esseri umani
estra roma il futuro cambia per esempio
qua non lasciate il gambia la mia idea
di futuro e di poter studiare lavorare
un giorno è come dite in italia a fare
famiglia avrebbe una moglie e dei figli
è stata davvero bello per faggi
poi però quando il vado diventato molto
duro
il mio futuro era tutto in una parola
salvarmi e sembrava davvero difficile e
io stavo molto male
quando un anno fa sono finalmente
arrivato in sicilia siracusa sono andata
a vivere a un centro di accoglienza
molto grande dove eravamo tutti contenti
di ferie vivi ma nessuno mi dicevo cosa
fare
non sapevo parlare italiano non andavo a
scuola il futuro era fermo poi qualcuno
abbia parlato di corso dove insegnano a
raccontare con le immagini 146 dirigenti
usando il nostro cellulare
a me piace raccontare mentre facevo le
video e per questo progetto ho
cominciato a guardare la realtà davanti
a me le persone del centro le partite di
calcio da una stanza da letto
il riso scotto che davano la comunità
sta imparando a raccontare con le
immagini ci sono le cose che fai che non
sa a quale ti servono ma le fai perché
ti fanno stare bene e credo che per
conseguire un domani è importante stare
bene poi senza darmi la mia di 24 ore
per preparargli mano trasferito a 200
chilometri da siracusa in una comunità
per i minori elisa con la quaglieni fa
dunque il posto non ti volevo andare ho
fatto di tutto ma non c'è stato niente
da fare e io ero veramente disperato
il giorno passeggiavo nella spiaggia
avevo trovato un piccolo chiosco chi
vendono bibite a panini il defy nome ha
fatto un regalo un po seri cameriere
avrai lavorato lì fino alla fine
dell'estate si dice il lavoro stagionale
e così era nel futuro in quel momento
era pure lui stagionale ma andava bene e
lui era felice perché avevo capito un
altro cosa sul futuro non è quello che
succede che a fai il tuo futuro
ma quelle che ne fai
certo la vita lì non era facile quando
tornava la sera ogni tanto in comunità
c'era un grande dell'ordine le serie
della massa per terra i bicchieri rotti
era sempre colpa di un ragazzino
italiano
i tredici anni che si chiama domenico un
remo nello forse più peggio quando l'ho
conosciuto di devo solo la parolaccia
non ascoltavo nessuno
facevo solo quelle che voleva lui a me
lui non mi piaceva e non avevo nessuna
voglia di parlarci poi un giorno ho
capito come di quest'ultimo solo non
parlavo con nessuno nessuno parlavo con
lui e mi ha fatto tanti tristezza di
vederlo così anche si era colpa sua non
è mai bello di essere soli allora mi
sono avvicinato e lo ha chiesto che fai
mi hai spiegato che non volevano fare
nella comunità perché noi sentiamo
libero
io conosco bene questa situazione allora
lei lo ha detto di andare a farsi una
doccia e di venire con me
non so cosa è successo in questione di
diverso ma forse per un attimo
lui non si è più sentito solo forse
quelle parole che li ho detto due parole
questi piccole vieni con me hanno
cambiato in un suo collo il futuro di
domenico da qui al giorno e siamo usciti
e non siamo più lasciati
siamo diventati come colore degli occhi
io sono il nero e lui è il bianco
nessuno si può separare dall'altro
facciamo tante cose insieme giochiamo
calcio
andiamo un display giochiamo biandino
parliamo tantissimo insieme e io ho
cominciato a fare del video della serie
vita insieme
domenico cambiato e tutta la comunità la
nottata non spacca più niente fumo meno
di te meno baronaggi va a scuola perché
è importante avere qualcuno vicino io
non l'ho avuto quindi so quando è bello
avere qualcuno che dà dei consigli chi
ti fa capire come comportarsi con gli
altri soprattutto quelle grandi perché
domenico non crede nessuno
per lui sono tutti bugiardi
io le ho detto davanti un bugiardo stai
zitto e vai per la tua strada
ora siamo in due un giorno sono tornato
da un viaggetto del nostro progetto
video lui mi ha abbracciato e mi ha dato
un bacino e mi ha detto due cose che era
la prima volta che battiamo una persona
di colore e che mi ha dato che sabato
perché hanno fatto vedere la strada
giusta e facevo parte della sua famiglia
era diventato suo fratello
così ho capito quelle due parole che li
chiamava detto mesi prima
vieni con me non avevano cambiato solo
il futuro di domenico ma anche il mio
così va ripensato tutte l'idea di futuro
che mi era portato indietro in questi
anni molte cose che volevo l'aveva
ottenuti sono salvo vado a scuola
avevo una fidanzata ma quelle che non
avevo mai pensato di il mio futuro e che
si potesse fare una famiglia con
sconosciuto che humour orfano senza
fratelli nato in un paesino del gambia
sei stato fratello maggiore di domenico
un ragazzino italiano di 13 anni
io ora da tutto questa esperienza ho
capito una cosa molto importante
dobbiamo smettere di dare l'importanza
hanno sorpassato sì è vero noi non
condividiamo lo stesso sangue la stessa
cultura alla storia del mio paese e deve
fare la vostra
ma sì ci diamo una mano e cd ma citiamo
nel passato allora siamo già nel futuro
un futuro mai più fermo e sicuramente il
migliore grazie
[Applauso]